[Music]  new at noon graduation at las vegas high  school this morning seniors at las vegas  high had a chance to walk across the  stage  and earn their diploma in person the  first ceremony was this morning on the  school's football field  principal ron garzon says it's an  exciting day especially after such a  tough year  every single student that i spoke with  was excited  at the prospects of being on our  football field on our campus  where they've created lots of lots of  positive memories and so  to end their high school tenure  on a positive note on a normal note  celebrating with their closest family  and friends  they are way more than excited  las vegas high also has a second  ceremony for graduation that's tonight  at seven  all across clark county school district  graduations last until next week